a woman accused of pushing an elderly
man
off a bus to his death facing a new
charge and a judge says she can still
remain
out of custody it is a story the i-team
has been following
vanessa murphy live in studio now to
explain a bit more vanessa
brian kadisha bishop faces a murder
charge and is out on bond for that
charge
now she's accused of stealing a rental
car prosecutors argued she should be in
jail but a judge
isn't convinced pro-tem judge nancy
becker made the decision today that
bishop can remain
out of custody despite that new charge
of grand larceny
bishop's attorneys claim she lent a
rental car to someone who didn't return
it
a prosecutor says this new charge shows
she doesn't understand the seriousness
of that murder charge
and in court she brought up the
following video showing the
confrontation
with serge fournier before that push i
want to warn our viewers the video
is disturbing
you see there khadisha bishop and the 74
year old man exchanged words before he
is pushed off the bus to his death
bishop's
child was with her in the murder case
she was granted 100 thousand dollar bail
with electronic
monitoring which prosecutors objected to
now bishop's next court appearance is
set for friday and a trial for that
murder charge
is set for october